jodie aujourd'hui je suis super content
parce qu'on se trouve sur un type
dernier il s'agit de notre nouveau let's
play l'année dernière nafa l'isolation
et cette fois on va faire un tilt d'inde
alors pour vous situer c'est un survival
horror à scénariser c'est un peu une
sorte de film interactif en fait sauf
que voilà il ya de l'horreur il y un
tueur qui veut nous tuer on est vu potes
qui sommes partis en vacances dans un
chalet il y aura un épisode de until now
mis en ligne le lundi jeudi et samedi
chaque épisode ce sera un chapitre
entier est apparemment si je me trompe
pas je crois qu'à neuf chapitres donc en
gros on est parti pour nos vidéos sur
une pile down et c'est les vidéos qui
sont en plus bien sûr de celle de
d'habitude le mardi mercredi et vendredi
voilà tout est clair on peut jouer la
plus petits décision peut changer le
futur de façon radicale vos actions
décideront la manière dont l'histoire se
déroule au sqbb fdp jeunesse est
scrupuleusement vos actions [ __ ] et
nous apprécions les salles on va
réfléchir 28 fois avant de songer à un
truc
voici donc le fameux chalets dans lequel
on est en vacances ouais il est massif
bonjour madame
hôpital aubin la vue du tueur quoi c'est
super marrant vaches au ballon du loup à
ça commence direct quoi on y va à cash
elle a fait quoi
elle mérite tourner autour
ok schiste mc obindé
ok qu'est ce qu'elles ont fait elles ont
fait un coup de [ __ ] à quelqu'un a
laissé rien de fou iphone cache cache
ok ils se planquent tous pour faire peur
à l'autre
on les salles aux vaches mike oui là
ah et les deux mèches le [ __ ] c'est
pas des blagues comme ça quand il ya un
tueur dehors plus tard gardez-le vous
êtes qu à mort elle l'a vu quand je joue
ça y est je joue oh la la la vache c'est
parti pour ce match mais sur un
dividende total ce sens qu'on va kiffer
à lui on peut pas le réveiller qu'est ce
qu'il fout mais une petite fille locle à
un petit taquet découvrez ce que font
les autres
ok c'est l'objectif en cours alors on
découvre les lieux quoi avant de se
faire trucider dans les mêmes lieux ça
didacticiel 8,6 du stick droit pour
regarder autour de vous les objets qui
brille peuvent être examinés matin
touche r2 pour prendre la bouteille
ouais ok sont complètement bourré
d'accord on sait juste que des petites
siestes une feuille anar tu es vraiment
belle dans ce t-shirt mais tulle et
sûrement encore plus quand tu ne l'as
pas bien dans la chambre d'amis à 2h du
mat mike dacor ac le piège
voilà donc ces elles comprennent comment
qui est venu à 2h du mat où ça nous mène
c'est mike a écrit le mot il a écrit
pour elle juste avant là là mais quel
dragueur il fait de la drogue ou y aller
c'est parti ah les [ __ ] au le get a
put tempo ciel turc est arrivé là il
arrive corps au [ __ ] opte a réveillé
josh rejoindre gemini josh n'est pas de
courage
s'il te plaît [ __ ] il est trop beau
rien annoncer un hacker partie la maison
métier script et hama ok on y va c'est
parti
surtout d'actions correct avant la fin
du temps rend plus tard ça c'est du cul
terreux sa carrière à le retrouver a
retrouvé des cultures la trouve un
rapide prudent rapides sont barrés state
on va y aller de son but 1 2 caps est
quoi je fais ça je me cache la cheville
oh là là le mauvais plan là la boîte
suivent le bruit suivent les pas j'ai vu
le bruit des souris cette décision j'ai
peur j'ai perdu parce qu elle va tomber
plus tard là bas à droite à droite suive
les pas qui voulait pas faire c'est
horrible quand on sait pas s'ils ont su
tueur en série a n'a juste pas toi y'a
pas que djabou vers quoi elle est ou
[ __ ] bras comme il ya plein de mortier
dans ces bois d'un feu pâle abc lama
waouh
waouh y possédait ce [ __ ] de serre est
là pour un chip lead time deux et sept
touchés avant bordel c'est quoi ça
emmerde
qu'est ce que c'est que ça what totem de
mort c'est quoi un totem de mort au fait
si les totems l'éventuelle mort de la
personne qui le trouvent les tribunes
jet penser que les papillons transporter
les rêves et les propositions chaque
totem prédit un avenir possible
cette manière de jouer qui déterminera
si ses profits se réaliseront ou non est
donc là il se doutait mais on doit
crever sur une pierre je sais que ça
peut arriver je dois faire en sorte que
ça n'arrive pas à quoi les [ __ ]
what do me tient alors slam qua non mais
please quoi ou alors c'est le sert qui
crachent dessus du feu du nez y a un
truc là bas tu fout quoi dame était bête
maintenant c'est nous qui ferons froid
mais non à la ola là
c'est quoi ça c'est quoi ça c'est quoi
ça conrad un coup à nos jeunes et ont
fait état le boulgour monde se péter la
cheville attendant on fait des sauts de
4 bet el tribus sur une palissade en
bois
on a perdu téléphone pour appeler
jouanno amis [ __ ] on est dans la merde
on est dans la merde
oh non c'est pas le tueur s'est pas tu
enfin déjà c'est le cers et ça c'est le
cerf
voilà
oui oui ta [ __ ] [ __ ] c'est quoi qui
crachent du feu bon gars qua non non non
non mon regard hagard à garma moyens la
main non je mourrais sokhiev pas pu j'ai
du temps laissé tomber nadal à chier
vaccaro qu'est la pierre la prophétie
s'est réalisée non l'analyste n'a mais
y'a pas déjà deux morts la ya deux morts
mais c'était quoi ce n'est qu'un masque
et un lance flamme quoi please
c'est quoi ça l'analyste c'est une
enquête ok on est un an après aux
actions oui vous êtes décidés à
participer au jeu
parfois tu as fois ces choses peuvent
être effrayantes voir des fientes même
rythme assuré que votre esprit son
accord c'est mon psy en fait c'est ça
prendre la carte assez hockey le test je
suis plus le nom mais cette bonne tête
je vous fait qu'ils aient encore envie
de lui mettre des petites claques alors
vas-y prend la main qu'est ce qu'il ya
et je suis qui en fait sa question c'est
qu'on ne sait pas quel personnage ou ok
donc c'est un chalet avec un épouvantail
horrible devant d'accord qu'est ce que
je ressens face à ça du bon gros malaise
quoi dubois
bah oui une bonne chose un épouvantail
des gueux là que me tuer l'épouvantail
met mal à l'aise j'ai peur de rester
seul chez moi tout seul pour sa part
certain temps alors à ses allées une
grosse tu vas te faire beau gars ben y'a
bon bah je me sentirai j'aurais peur je
me tapais temps c'est intrigant il a dit
c'est ça c'est mon psy en fait au revoir
le psy à bientôt
voilà je fais je donne mon chèque de 250
euros au revoir il est malsain je n'aime
pas du tout mais c'est fait exprès
personne ne l'a mis 6 7 6 sony computer
entertainment représente on vient faire
le trou je suis content je suis trop
heureux de faire ça avec vous c'est un
truc de dingue
voilà là le mec il a des caméras
non ok donc là en fait on est l'année
qui suit celle où les deux soeurs sont
mortes tombées dans le ravin lagoon du
mec jaloux qui lançait des flammes
suite à la demande de josh qui est le
frère des deux soeurs qui sont morts
tout le monde se réunit de nouveau dans
le chalet voilà ce qui est la pire idée
du monde on est d'accord
premier chapitre le met au mori 10h
jusqu'à l'aube à ok non mais non mais
attends mais arrête pas d janek please
laisse nous le temps d'au moins deux
raids arriver le mec il est pacha le
chaos plus de sa meilleure amie d'anna
sam bienveillante audacieuse oui juste à
côté
c'est un animal ça par contre c'est pas
un sam chemin de la station du
téléphérique 21h02 les portes sont
bloquées escalade crise à ok non mais
c'est bloqué à elle tente quand même par
le mur là regardez moi ça c'est parfait
c'est imprudent prudent prudent voilà
les basses eaux jack un trait d'humour
il passe à décoller l scaldis armure et
lorsque ne bougeait pas est à l'écran
maintenez la manette sans fil aussi
mobile que possible il va manger on doit
regarder annoncé quoi ça les tribus qui
vivaient autrefois dans ces montagnes
penser que les papillons transporter les
rêves et prophéties de possibles futurs
la couleur de papillons indiquer la
nature de la prophétie mort des
papillons noirs annoncé la mort de la
personne en train de rêver danger des
papillons rouges prévenait de l'arrivée
d'un événement dangereux tragédie
papillon marron conseil papillon jaune
chance papillons blancs ça c'est un truc
dont il faut se souvenir je suis sûr ah
bah voilà fameux prophétie amassé un
totem elle retournait révélera un papier
ont coloré et la prémonition d'un futur
éventuel
ok donc là c'est c'est jaune
totem du conseil c'est noté c'est noté
c'est noté on se souviendra [ __ ] ça va
être des énigmes et où le futur est
incertain la réalisation d'une prophétie
dépendra des choix que vous effectuerez
oh là là mais nous met une pression en
la bassée de téléphérique donc elle
rejoint crise à son téléphone
fouinez ou fermer les salles twin et
sartrouville est complice du psychopathe
mais je suis of un effet papillon
apparaît lorsque vos actions modifier la
trame narrative du jeu olala faire le
con mais receveur albé gains pour ashley
protecteur méthodique comics je les aime
bien à temps voire n'est pas mon
assistante 6 merci de m'avoir prévenu
mais j'avais prévenir c'est arrivé trop
tôt crise indices trouvés avis de
recherche
il ya un mec qui recherchait un mec 88
dans les blacks pines recherché pour un
incendie criminel au premier degré ainsi
que pour diverses menaces de mort ok
d'élections le téléphérique
et oui comme avocat regardez moi ça je
suis sûr qu'il va s'arrêter
c'est pas possible ok nand est arrivé
sain et sauf et ya quelqu'un qui nous
attend jesse la nouvelle copine de maina
yves irrévérencieuse assurer aux caisses
noté
elle part seule déjà et carmaux
schizophrène à sérieuse allez sortez les
enfants venaient au wac qui fait notre
chalet c'est quoi je fais que ça m'a
appris on dirait que quelqu'un a un
faible pour notre cher camarade délégués
de classe michael monde a annoncé la
lettre qu'il joue un rôle à moi je vais
pas t'expliquer je suis avec maïté
touquet côté ville des mille îles c'est
vrai et fier de l'être était vraiment
trop quoi du chien tu peux nous le dira
on sait garder des secrets
peu importe
vous découvrirez tout voilà vous verrez
bien je suis avec lui vous allez le voir
vous allez prendre en flagrant délit
dans la chambre a dit en premier
ouais je vais attendre un peu ici pour
voir d'autres arrivent
tu veux dire bas à ok et donc elles sont
très honnêtes en poste des côtés de
téléphérique emilie ex de mike d'accord
donc ça c'est l'ex de miley
entreprenante persuasive intelligente je
vais bien je dormis limmat du nouveau
copain d'emilie ambitieux sportifs
motivés
j'aime un peu moi je gère mieux les
faits avant que tout le monde soit dans
le chalet les gens se rejoignent quoi
donc on découvre les portraits de chacun
leur relation de chacun avec chacun ses
collants et je porte les bagages de
cette femme c'est scandaleux
qu'est ce que tu en penses c'est mike
attardé va [ __ ] je te déteste
débrouillards déterminé persuasif
tu peut vous être utile à se mettre dans
l'ambiance sérieux tu te fous de ma
gueule
c 'est détendre l'atmosphère m pas comme
ça comme quoi
arrête tes conneries tu as toujours été
comme ça aulas et violent avec elle utah
menaçant où nous sommes tous amis ici à
menaçants ils parlent mal c'est ma
copine de basile michael tu vas devoir
tiff est ok emilie et moi on est
ensemble et il n'y a rien à dire à la
femme
et je vais pas te le répéter
est-ce qu'on se comprend bien je pensais
qu'on pouvait dépasser ça
notre pote non tu fermes ta bouche que
pas mal que plainte
je vais continuer mon chemin bon ben ok
nature et hayden
du coup il sait balle et on est plus que
2 puis par terre je regrette de france a
pour moi s'il te plaît il faut que
j'avais trouvé ça m' hockey watts elle
veut rejoindre la course et de grosses
mito qui y est presque
c'est importe c'est menteuse non je
sortais menteuse non je te laisse pas
seul je pense vraiment que tu devrais
pas tu dors pas y aller tout seul c'est
sérieux il fait froid la nuit tombe
exactement
il est donc tu vas me protéger de la
exactement je vais laisser nos affaires
mais voilà personne valais vaud les
maths
tu te fous non non tu peux même pas me
laisser celle samyn odom et essaie de
faire voilà tu as ton avec ton ex pour
moi tu m'écoutes jamais pourquoi tourner
en question tout ce que je disais je
je sais juste être gentil quand tu veux
être serviable tac à remonter toutes les
affaires au chalet le plus vite possible
ok ok en lorraine le pote testicules à l
est de mèche avec un truc hein je vous
le dis elle là il ya un problème un
alors qui est cette femme qui observe
ashley a le béguin pour chris studieuse
curieuse honnête
ouais d'accord elle observe
tranquillement à bas on voit quelqu'un
assis qui attend en bas c'est l'autre
qui attention dans son petit makada
d'amour
ah les observe je crois que quelqu'un se
montre un peu trop amicale et pas
vraiment dans le bon sens dit voilà je
vous avais dit quoi devrais peut-être
interruption youtube à la gelée de faire
peur oui mais sans faire peur à ses
droits c'est drôle amusant est ce que tu
regardes tu as vu un truc intéressant
j'espère garder vas-y regarde
hassar a créé des tensions on va il n'y
a pas de psychopathie pause buts et
entre eux il va voir sa copine parler à
son ex
je vous l'avais dit moi je m'en fous je
veux qu'ils sachent la vérité qu'ils
sachent qu'elle est vraiment voilà voilà
voilà
jamais la capitale
ah bah oui et non mais faut qu'ils
soient au courant tel n'est pas le cas
chez dom faut qu'ils règlent les
histoires on a mis la merde prend là bas
je suis content
jessica elle attend toujours quoi à
21h40 livre portable portable comme ça
je peux enlever des swaps et quelqu'un
s'il ya problème toujours après moyens
j'en ai marre c'est un peu bof ça faire
un boulot nage bras tendus vers la tête
et bras pleins torse bon gars allez
music is more from all l'aube les côtes
souci
hop là c'est pas mal ça au loiseau
loiseau quand je me souviens que c'était
un indice est un instit alors ça ok son
show je vais tomber dessus au regard des
oiseaux au [ __ ] c'est lundi parfois ne
rien faire et le meilleur des choix je
fais rien j'ai pu vraiment pas envie de
le chouchouter
j'ai vraiment pas envie de ajouté j'ai
vraiment pas envie de le chouchouter et
si j'avais chuté l'oiseau sur l'échangé
quoi ah oui son total i love quoi on
embrasse ont fait une boule ont fait une
boule voilà il n'y a pas de respect un
faux pas des honoraires rentrer au
chalet oui allez on y va
ok alors est ce qu'on se retrouve tous
dans le chalet [ __ ] j acques de
psychopathe voilà pour la première fois
je bout d'impatience à nouveau chez le
psy pitre c'est le prix de sava et vous
oui ok quoi des kleenex sur votre bureau
je déteste ce mec les hommes
m'inquiètent les femmes inquiètes à les
mecs quand même des avions de la foule
[ __ ] j'ai j'aime pas les deux les
avions comme c'est le pire c'est le pire
le vertige ou housse noyer [ __ ] je
détestais de aussi à élever le vide
quand même mais ça fait plus peur le
serpent le rat le serpent le pistolet ou
le couteau le pistolet le serpent ou le
cafard a le cafard les insectes
aaaah ça me temps il est incroyable ses
personnages il est trop bien fait oh la
la
les épouvantails où les clowns les clous
puisque les épouvantails et là ça change
la trame scénaristique et on va se
retrouver avec un avion de la foule
un clown le sens me dégoûte j'ai peur
des corbeaux le sang le sang [ __ ] t'es
chiant en salle au clown ou zombies
clown sans ou orages pas peur de l'orage
mais dans je vais avoir peur de l'orage
de grêle et l'orage
ouais moi je regrette pas ma vie mali
mali et son régime a eu du mal il va
revoir sa [ __ ] de fenay web on voit
les gens c'est bien fort de cette
première épisode sur gildas j'espère que
ça vous a plu et c'est le cas n'hésitez
pas aimé la vidéo pour montrer que seul
et même à vous plaire et que le jeu vous
plaît surtout c'est important j'espère
que vous allez l'apprécier autant que
moi j'espère que l'on taj est assez bien
fait je retire vraiment eu ce qui est
totalement inutile et je laisse vraiment
ce qui permet de bien comprendre
l'histoire de tout suivre
voilà j'ai pas d'autre chose à dire à
part que ça change pas mal de ce qu'on
fait d'habitude mais c'est en plus de ce
qu'on fait d'habitude ça remplacement à
ce qu'on fait d'habitude on bombe à ceux
qui aiment et dont vous avez tout gagné
à bientôt six a toujours dit tu es
devant jeter clair comme d'hab ça va
être un [ __ ] d'animal vivant inscrits
au non cumul à se passer de profiteurs